la séance est reprise
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restantes en
discussions du projet de loi met en fin
au régime d'exception créé pour lutter
contre l'épidémie liée à la covid-19 et
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe bar
rapporteur pour le Sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire pour 5
minutes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente mon compteur
indique 12 minutes
puis-je parler
bon bah j'y vais madame la Présidente ou
le président
madame le Président Monsieur le Ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois mais chers collègues ainsi
s'achève un processus assez rapide nous
permettant après tant de discussion
législative de sortir définitivement du
régime de l'état d'urgence sanitaire et
du régime de gestion de la crise
sanitaire nous y avons veillé nous avons
voulu rendre les choses claires et nous
avons convaincu la santé nationale et le
gouvernement de nous suivre sur ce
terrain de la clarté
donc Nous abrogeons aujourd'hui même
c'est deux régimes temporaires
en cas de crise sanitaire à l'avenir
si le gouvernement a besoin de
pouvoir exceptionnel il devra les
négocier un par un avec le Parlement
nous ne faisons pas crédit nous
demandons que quand il s'agit de
restreindre les libertés il y ait un
débat parlementaire c'est notre rôle
constitutionnel nous tenons à l'exercer
dans de bonnes conditions
nous avons également fait en sorte que
les Français puissent voyager facilement
en Europe même si l'un des pays membres
de l'Union européenne devait ériger des
barrières sanitaires à l'entrée sur son
territoire les Français pourront
disposer jusqu'à la fin de l'application
du règlement européen c'est-à-dire le 30
juin prochain en utilisant les
instruments électroniques les plus
simples grâce à une prolongation
partielle et avec le consentement de
chacun du système d'information qui a
été mis en place pour lutter contre le
covid-19
enfin il a été décidé que
deux dispositifs pourraient être mis en
vigueur par le gouvernement si des
raisons sanitaires majeures le
justifiait premier dispositif pour les
voyageurs venant d'un pays où aurait
émergé invariant dangereux du covid dans
ces pays il faudra si le gouvernement le
décide produire un test négatif avant de
pouvoir rejoindre la France
mais les circonstances sont clairement
définies dans le texte on ne pourrons on
ne pourra pas se servir pour autre chose
de ce dispositif et le deuxième élément
bien c'est tout simplement pour protéger
nos outre-mer dont l'offre hospitalière
de soins est facilement saturé si il y a
de nouveau crises sanitaire si l'offre
de soins est saturée dans un dans une
collectivité d'outre-mer le gouvernement
pourra décider que l'accès à ces
collectivités sera réservée à des
personnes pouvant produire un test
négatif
pas d'autres l'instrument de contrôle
que ces deux-là et ces deux-là sont
actionnables dans des en respectant des
conditions extrêmement restreintes par
ailleurs nous avons veillé à ne pas
prendre parti dans le débat d'ordre
sanitaire
touchant à la réintégration des
personnels qui n'ont pas voulu se faire
vacciner alors qu'ils font l'objet d'une
obligation vaccinale nous avons pensé
que ça n'était pas notre rôle que seul
une décision
médicale scientifique
pouvait justifier la réintégration de
ces personnel tout en rappelant qu'ils
n'ont pas été licenciés mais seulement
suspendus et que par conséquent dès la
fin de la crise sanitaire c'est-à-dire
dès que les motifs médicaux qui
justifient l'obligation vaccinale auront
disparu ce sera constater nous pourrons
déclencher ce constat par la Haute
Autorité de Santé afin de pouvoir
réintégrer les personnes nécessaires je
rappelle que ce sont pour la majeure
partie des personnels soignants ils ne
sont peu nombreux mais il y a aussi des
personnels administratives de l'hôpital
ou des établissements médico-sociaux
pour personnes âgées et handicapées mais
aussi des sapeurs-pompiers c'est très
important que on puisse même faire
rentrer au travail progressivement ces
personnels en fonction de leur degré
d'éloignement par rapport aux personnes
vulnérables voilà madame la Présidente
la déclaration que je voulais faire en
début de séance en me réjouissant du bon
accord de mon point de vue qui a été
trouvé avec nos collègues députés et
avec l'accord du gouvernement
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur la
parole est à Monsieur François Braun
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
madame le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs après
l'Assemblée nationale d'hier il revient
désormais au Sénat de se prononcer sur
le compromis atteint en commission mixte
paritaire sur ce projet de loi
ce texte aura fait l'objet d'un vif
débat
mais la CMP a finalement et c'est
heureux aboutit un texte qui entérine la
fin de l'état d'urgence sanitaire et du
régime de sortie au 31 juillet prochain
tout en maintenant les dispositions
minimales et nécessaires pour continuer
à protéger les Français surtout ce texte
est le résultat d'une méthode que je
souhaite mettre en oeuvre avec vous sur
la durée dans cette situation politique
inédite
cette méthode répond à deux maîtres mots
le dialogue et le compromis toujours
sans compromission
c'est toutes les possibilités qu'offre
le bicamerisme le tout au service de la
qualité du droit et de la protection de
nos concitoyens vous savez que j'y suis
profondément attaché
oui ce texte est une œuvre collective
alliant les groupes de la majorité et
les groupes d'opposition qui ont répondu
à notre appel à ne pas relâcher
d'efforts face au virus
je tiens donc aujourd'hui à remercier
l'ensemble des acteurs de ce compromis
je pense en particulier au rapporteur
des deux chambres dont Philippe Bas ici
présent je pense aussi au président de
la commission des lois François Noël
buffet je pense également aux
responsable de textes des groupes du
Sénat et je veux plus largement saluer
le travail de l'ensemble des
parlementaires mobilisés sur ce texte
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs le projet de loi sur lequel
vous allez vous prononcer est un
bouclier nécessaire face à une épidémie
de covid-19 qui n'a pas encore dit son
dernier mot
nous nous trouvons désormais dans la
phase descendante de la 7e vague due au
sous variant de Micron BA4 et Béa 5
toutefois nous devons rester vigilant
cette épidémie nous a appris depuis plus
de deux ans l'humidité et nous ne
pouvons exclure l'apparition de nouveaux
variants potentiellement plus
préoccupants en somme comme je l'ai déjà
rappelé nous devrons toujours et encore
être prêt à nous adapter au service de
nos concitoyens notamment les plus
fragiles
c'est pour cette raison que ce projet de
loi est important et que le texte issu
de la CMP est soutenu par le
gouvernement
d'une part ce texte en terrine
conformément à l'engagement du
gouvernement à la situation sanitaire
hadate la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et marque un retour au droit
commun qui est bienvenu ces dispositions
devenaient caduques le premier août et
vous avez choisi de l'écrire
explicitement dans la loi
il ne serait désarmé plus possible
d'exiger le Pass sanitaire pour des
actes de la vie courante comme par
exemple aller au restaurant
d'autre part ce texte nous préserve des
outils nécessaires conformément au texte
initial présenté par le gouvernement
pour faire face à une éventuelle
recrudescence des cas de covid-19 des
dispositions ciblées sont en effet
maintenues pour pouvoir suivre
l'évolution de l'épidémie pour protéger
les Français et pour leur permettre de
voyager dans les pays qui maintiennent
des restrictions de circulation en somme
avec ce texte nous concilions de manière
proportionnée la protection des
Françaises et des Français avec le
respect des libertés individuelles
auxquelles je le sais vous êtes tous ici
attachés
surtout le dialogue entre les deux
chambres et notamment le travail
exigeant réalisé par la commission des
Lois du Sénat ont permis d'enrichir ce
texte ainsi la prolongation jusqu'au 30
juin 2023 de l'existence de SIDEP qui
enregistre les résultats de tests de
dépistage à la covid-19 nous permet de
disposer plus longtemps d'une boussole
très utile
cet amendement nous met également en
cohérence avec le règlement européen du
14 juin 2021 relatif au certificat covid
numérique de l'Union européenne cela
permettra donc à nos concitoyens de
voyager à l'étranger comme tous les
autres Européens dans le respect des
règles établies
de même la commission mix paritaire a
également permis de confirmer l'apport
très important voter au Sénat prévoyant
la possibilité pour le gouvernement
d'opérer des contrôles sanitaires aux
frontières ainsi qu'entre l'hexagone et
l'outre-mer vous le savez cet outil est
essentiel pour nous permettre de réagir
rapidement en cas d'apparition n'avait
rien préoccupant ou à risque avéré
j'avais dit après la suppression de cet
article que je voulais me battre pour le
réintégrer je me félicite donc du fait
que vous ayez permi son retour je
remercie à nouveau Philippe Bas et des
groupes de gauche de droite et du centre
qui ont largement voté cette disposition
en revanche vous avez souhaité que cet
article soit limité au test de dépistage
de la covid-19 alors que dans son projet
initial le gouvernement visait aussi des
preuves de vaccination ou de
rétablissement
l'objectif était de pouvoir protéger de
la manière la plus efficace possible
donc aux citoyens avec une boîte à
outils permettant nous adapter à toutes
les situations et cela en cohérence a
été choix de nos pays voisins au plus
loin toutefois le compromis
parlementaire s'est établi ainsi
par ailleurs la question de la
réintégration des professionnels soumis
à l'obligation vaccinale a également
fait l'objet à mon sens d'un traitement
équilibré et responsable dans ce texte
je soutiens le consensus issu de la CMP
qui s'appuie comme je l'ai toujours
souhaité sur l'avis des scientifiques et
de la Haute Autorité de santé
enfin le Parlement a souhaité que le
Gouvernement présente un rapport qui
expose le cadre juridique existant pour
lui et contre les pandémies et les
évolutions possibles pour limiter le
recours au régime d'exception je
répondrai à cette demande et je
m'attacherai à ce que ce rapport puis au
mieux éclairer et enrichir le travail de
contrôle et d'évaluation du Parlement
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs je terminerai en un mot le
texte sur lequel vous allez vous
prononcer aujourd'hui et le fruit d'un
travail parlementaire consensuel et
exigeant que le gouvernement respecte
c'est aussi et surtout un outil
profondément nécessaire de protection de
la santé des Français à laquelle
par-delà les différences politiques nous
sommes tous ici attachés je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre nous passons
aux explications de votre des groupes à
raison d'un orateur par groupe et la
première d'entre elles madame Nadine
bellurault pour le groupe les
républicains pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues nous poursuivons cet
après-midi
par l'examen des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire d'un 13ème
projet de loi sanitaire tout comme ce
fut le cas par le passé ce texte
comprend donc un certain nombre de
mesures de dispositions destinées à
doter les pouvoirs publics d'outils
servant à accompagner la prévention et
la lutte contre l'épidémie les enjeux et
les cadres juridiques nous sont donc
familiers cependant contrairement au
passé ce texte
comme vous le savez se caractérise par
un contexte particulier puisque les
régimes dérogatoires mis en place durant
les deux dernières années arriveront à
leur terme ce dimanche la question était
donc de savoir quels étaient les outils
que nous souhaitions conserver
temporairement or alors que la 7 les
vagues de l'épidémie de covid-19 est
toujours en cours le Gouvernement a
souhaité conserver la prolongation de
deux dispositifs les systèmes
d'information SIDEP et antique
et le mécanisme permetant de
l'instauration de contrôle au frontières
c'est moins évidemment par rapport au
lourdes dérogation et aux régimes
d'exception des lois sanitaires
précédentes mais c'est accordé encore
des pouvoirs de contrôle important à
l'occasion des déplacements ce que le
Gouvernement a souhaité la teneur des
débats d'ailleurs on a attesté à
l'occasion de son examen à l'Assemblée
nationale pour cette raison le Sénat a
suivi les préconisations de son
rapporteur philiba c'était un saluer son
travail afin de remanier en profondeur
le projet de loi dans le sens d'une plus
grande proportionnalité responsabilité
écartée pour commencer nous avons décidé
d'inclure explicitement dans la loi
l'abrogation des différents dispositifs
des rogatoires de droit commun qui
s'était accumulées dans les textes
depuis mars 2020 à l'avenir réactiver un
régime d'exception nécessitera de
remettre entièrement l'ouvrage sur le
métier devant le Parlement
ensuite nous avons voté l'ajustement du
dispositif juridique concernant le
système d'information qui permettra de
conserver l'accès des Français au
certificat covid numérique de l'Union
européenne entre janvier et juin 2023
sans dérogation au secret médical ni au
contact de tracing autour de la question
cruciale des soignants et autres
personnels concernés par l'obligation
vaccinale nous avons souhaité offrir une
perspective de réintégration au
personnel suspendus qui ont
nécessairement vocation un jour ou
l'autre à être réintégré la décision de
cette réintégration comme l'a dit le
rapporteur était juste laissé jusqu'ici
au seul gouvernement le Sénat a fait en
sorte que ce soit la Haute Autorité de
santé qui puisse en décider le moment
venu
enfin il y a le fameux article 2 face
aux incompréhensions et aux inquiétudes
légitimes qu'il a pu susciter nous avons
proposé un dispositif juridique dans son
application qui est exigeant à l'égard
de l'exécutif et cibler en effet il
n'est plus question de donner carte
blanche au gouvernement pour instaurer
des contrôles sanitaires généralisés
mais plutôt de limiter cette possibilité
aux voyageurs en provenance de pays où
l'apparition de nouveaux variants pour
être engendré des risques sanitaires
particulièrement graves en cas
d'activation de ce dispositif les
voyageurs concernés devront fournir un
test virologique négatif il prévoit
également cela a été dit un traitement
spécifique le désoutre-mer ou la
question de la saturation potentielle
des services de santé se posent long
terme encore dramatique beaucoup plus
inquiétant qu'en métropole enfin en
cohérence avec ces positions durant les
lois sanitaires passées le Sénat avait
prévu que le gouvernement soit tenu de
demander au législateur la prolongation
de toutes ces mesures au-delà d'une
durée initiale limitée c'est donc avec
satisfaction que je constate qu'il fut
possible d'arriver à un accord
constructif sans compromission
comme au Sénat autour du texte
sénatorial en commission mixte paritaire
bien sûr ce texte fut modifié en partie
ainsi la durée initiale des mesures de
contrôle que j'évoquais à l'instant a
été prolongée d'un à deux mois après les
échanges en commission mixte mais
l'essentiel a été voté et la majorité du
groupe la majorité du groupe LR votera
ce texte merci
la parole est à Monsieur Guy benaroche
pour le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire pour 5 minutes chers
collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues allez déjà aller à
Jacques thaeste faute de mieux voilà ce
que se sont dit nombre de participants à
cette CMP le texte a été écrit négocié
en amont de sa réunion par les
rapporteurs si personne ne reproche ses
échanges informelles tous enfin sans
faire républicaine RREM regrette ce
conclave pression P et espère que ça ne
devienne pas une habitude certes nous
savions bien et la vie ici d'ailleurs
que le texte du sida était déjà
l'aboutissement d'une négociation entre
le gouvernement et la droite c'est la
toriale la CMP n'a donc pu servir au
parlementaire présent qui a exprimé leur
regret de ne pas pouvoir participer à
une réelle négociation du texte
certains aspects de ce texte sont à
saluer la sortie de l'état d'urgence
rendant tout ambition de réactivation
par le gouvernement soumise à
acceptation d'une nouvelle loi par le
Parlement la prise en compte des acteurs
locaux avec l'article 2 qui prévoit le
rôle majeur des élus locaux des
outrebers au corps pour demander la mise
en œuvre ou la levée des mesures de
contrôle lors des déplacements et de
saluant le travail du rapporteur et de
la commission des lois à ce sujet mais
pour autant la mise en oeuvre de ces
contrôles est possible pour deux mois au
lieu d'un comme initialement prévu la
CMP donne donc tout simplement plus de
pouvoir au gouvernement quand on se
retourne sur les deux années passées de
gestion de la crise quel dommage sur
l'article 1 nous regrettons l'absence de
prise en compte des remarques de la CNIL
demandant d'évaluation de l'impact du
dispositif sidap l'article 2 réécrit par
la majorité sédatoriale reste trop
problématique à nos yeux
certes il limite la présentation d'un
certificat de voyage aux personnes
venant de l'étranger sur le sol français
ou à toute personne souhaitant dans les
collectivités ultramarines mais ils
gardent cette obligation dès l'âge de 12
ans et n'aura pas les tests gratuits
pour tous notre groupe reste persuadé
que toute modifications significative
des libertés telles que celle d'aller
veut dire doit se faire de manière
concertée mais surtout éclairé et
précise éclairez en ce que le Parlement
doit bénéficier des mêmes informations
que l'exécutif il est regrettable pour
ne pas dire plus que deux soyons pas
destinataire de manière concombitante au
gouvernement au président des travaux du
conseil scientifique précise aussi bien
que la réécriture de l'article 2 parle
de menace sanitaire grave ou de risque
de saturation du système de santé encore
une fois cela est trop imprécie ou du
moins l'astro de marge d'appréciation le
refus du gouvernement de maître des
seuils ne nous étonne plus guère
néanmoins vu que les seuls seuils
d'alerte qu'il s'était lui-même a posé
depuis quelques pour moi non finalement
eu aucun impact sur sa propre gestion de
la crise quant à la saturation du
système de santé je vous ferai pas aux
forces en affirmant que nous ne
pourrions dès aujourd'hui argumenter
quel est ta tête pour le reste
l'ensemble des autres mesures de veille
et de sécurité sanitaire brille par leur
absence masse en lieu clos FFP2 contrôle
des prix des FFP2 contrôle de la qualité
des de l'air bien avant que le
gouvernement engage la discussion sur la
troisième dose nous l'avions alerté sur
les disparités vaccinales lui demandant
de s'attacher à comprendre et combattre
de tels déséquilibres et pourtant alors
qu'appe plus d'un quart de plus de 75
ans un schéma vaccinal complet de doses
plus de rappel le gouvernement détourne
le regard des plus fragiles des plus
précaires des plus éloignés de
l'épicentre de notre vie sociale j'en
profite pour attirer l'attention du
gouvernement sur la nouvelle urgence de
santé publique internationale décrétée
par l'OMS en fin de semaine dernière
pourquoi l'État n'arrive-t-il pas
enclencher de vaccination massive contre
manque épox à l'image de ce qui a été
fait contre le covid sur le terrain
s'interroge y aura-t-il assez de doses
de vaccin pourquoi la campagne de
vaccination est-elle silence il n'y a
pas de problème de stock de vaccin ou
dit-on du côté de la direction générale
de la santé bien que les mêmes ne
puissent en fait rien nous dire sur
l'état de ses stocks en raison du secret
défense
pour en revenir au covid ce texte prend
toujours pas en compte les propositions
portées pendant le groupe quel devrait
être la première mesure prioritaire face
à un virus un virus qui circule dans
l'air elle devrait toucher la
circulation dans l'air et pourtant
toujours aucun plat aux mesures solides
sur l'air des lieux fermés comme les
écoles dans la sécurisation doit être
votre priorité nous attendions des
mesures fortes débattement pour aller
vers les populations dans vaccinées des
mesures claires sur le prix des Basques
efficaces comme les FFP2 la gratuité des
tests de dépistage particulièrement
essentiels pour ne pas faire des ultra
barreaux et des Français de l'étranger
des citoyens de ce godzone des rappels
forts de l'importance des gestes
barrières pour de parfaire du vaccin ou
du Pass un outil à l'effet pervers nous
souhaitons des discussions éclairées sur
l'avancée des données de la science sur
l'efficacité éventuelle des vaccins sur
des nouveaux variants ou sur la
nécessité ou pas de conserver les
données en jeu dans l'article a nous
demandions des actes et un
accompagnement financier sur la qualité
de l'air de nos écoles mais de fois
repousser désormais promis par le
président de la République en fait nous
proposions un dialogue réel sur les
dangers connus les dangers prévisibles
et les retours d'expérience de la
gestion de ces deux dernières années par
votre gouvernement rien de cela n'est
alors du jour de ce texte aussi notre
groupe s'abstiendra
chers
présidente Eliane assassy pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste pour 5 minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues nous voilà semble-t-il au
terme de l'examen du 11e texte sur la
situation sanitaire liée à l'épidémie de
covid-19 et avec ses conclusions de CMP
au terme également de tout régime
juridique d'exception à la matière dans
l'absolu c'est une bonne chose d'autant
que cette fois étant donné le tout
nouveau rapport de force au Parlement
les mesures adoptées dans notre
assemblée ont été conservées il ne sera
donc plus possible pour le gouvernement
de réactiver simplement un pass
sanitaire ou vaccinal ou encore de
confiner la population sans repasser
devant le Parlement avec un nouveau
texte et de nouvelles mesures qui
seraient alors débattues et votées c'est
ce qui implique l'abrogation complète
des dispositifs exceptionnels de lutte
contre la pandémie
cette mesure emporte notre approbation
tout comme l'instauration d'un mécanisme
de protection sanitaire ou aux
frontières si un nouveau variant très
dangereux apparaît un test pourrait
alors être exigé pour l'accès au
territoire nous n'y sommes pas
défavorables non plus quand même à un
des vols près
l'applicabilité de cette mesure aux
jeunes de 12 à 18 ans nous avions
proposé en séance que le certificat
sanitaire de voyage ne soit pas
applicable pour les 12-18 ans
considérant que la jeunesse de notre
pays devait maintenant être épargnés par
toute forme de mesures restrictives
largement délétère pour leur état de
santé psychique notamment comme l'avait
relevé à plusieurs reprises à Défenseur
des droits notamment comme d'ailleurs
pour les enfants
âgés de 0 à 12 ans l'ensemble des jeunes
mineurs devraient être épargnés par ce
genre de mesure une fois pour toutes
pour les 12 saisons notamment qui sont
soumis au choix de leurs parents en
matière de vaccination cela n'est pas
entendable par ailleurs
nous sommes largement interrogatifs sur
le sort qui serait également réservé à
nos concitoyens ultramarins si ce
certificat sanitaire de voyage devait
entrer en vigueur nous proposions
également en séance que pour la mise en
place de cette mesure les élus
ultramarins est un droit d'initiative
qui mieux que et elle peut avoir une
connaissance assez fine des systèmes
hospitaliers outre-mer et de leur
saturation enfin sur la question de la
réintégration des personnels non
vaccinés notre rapporteur a décidé
d'évacuer la question renvoyant la
décision à la Haute Autorité de santé
que le pour le que le Parlement pourra
saisir et qui décidera de la
réintégration de ces personnels s'il est
constaté que l'obligation vaccinale
n'est plus médicalement justifiée nous
pensons pour notre part que ces
personnels devraient immédiatement être
réintégré comme chacun sait le vaccin
n'empêche pas d'être porteur du virus et
c'est d'ailleurs bien la logique que
vous avez adopté mes chers collègues en
instaurant un certificat sanitaire de
voyage nécessitant uniquement un test
négatif et non un schéma vaccinal
complet de plus si ces personnel avaient
été suspendus ce contre quoi ne nous
étions fermement opposés c'était pour
protéger les plus vulnérables au service
desquels ils étaient amenés à travailler
et non pour les protéger eux-mêmes d'un
risque de contamination aujourd'hui nous
est présenté le schéma inverse ceci
devrait continuer à être suspendu car
leur non vaccination les exposeraient à
développer une forme de covid dangereuse
pour leur propre santé vous voyez où ils
vont venir les arguments médicaux ou
sanitaires restent avant tout des
arguments politiques et nous ne sommes
pas dupe voilà pour ce qui est du texte
qui reste à conclure définitivement
aujourd'hui toutefois il y a des trous
dans la raquette nombreuses sont les
raisons qui nous poussent à pencher d'un
vote qui aurait vous conduira une
abstention étant donné la réécriture de
notre commission des lois à un vote
comme la noter le Conseil d'État dans
son avis si la situation sanitaire
semble stable et sous contrôle et bien
que les nouvelles admissions à l'hôpital
tendent à augmenter légèrement ces
indicateurs doivent être mis en
perspective avec les fragilités que
connaît le système de soins or que
propose le Gouvernement en la matière
rien vivre avec le virus ne consisterait
ne consisterait-il pas à engager une
réforme d'ampleur face à l'état
d'urgence de nos hôpitaux qui lui n'a
jamais cessé et face à la case
généralisée et désormais totalement
assumée de notre système public
hospitalier monsieur le ministre que
vous inspire les quelques 150 services
d'urgence qui ont manifesté leur
détresse depuis mes derniers que vous
inspire l'hémorragie de fermeture de
ludopito il s'agit là d'une question ou
deux questions cruciales à laquelle
malgré toutes les alertes nous donnerons
sans réponse sérieuse pour toutes ces
raisons vous l'aurez compris les
sénatrices et les sénateurs du groupe
CRCE eux voteront contre ce texte qui
est loin très loin d'être à la hauteur
merci la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
bonne Carrère pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 5 minutes chacun
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur ministre
monsieur président des commissions des
lois monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
mes chers collègues notre groupe va
voter le texte qui est présenté il tient
un effet participé à participer à cette
allégresse collective ou à cette joie
collective puisque le texte va être
largement approuvé y compris par vous
mais ces ministres vous devez indiquer
avec le sens du lieu compromis que vous
avez souligné même si nous avions cru
entendre lors des débats que sur le
certificat de vaccination vous pouviez
avoir une appréciation sanitaire et
cette idée n'a pas totalement quitté
votre esprit puisque nous avons cru
l'entendre tout à l'heure
si notre groupe va soutenir ce texte
c'est parce qu'effectivement nous sommes
106 premièrement à l'abrogation express
de toutes les dispositions qui étaient
liées à l'état d'urgence et à la sortie
de crise nous avons souvent insisté sur
les conditions relativement
divertissibles des textes qui nous
avaient été soumis pour apprécier cet
abrogation nous approuvons également
l'idée de la prolongation du système de
collecte statistiques il y a
effectivement une aisance pour nos
concitoyens à présenter le justificatif
de leur situation avec la petite
application correspondante notamment à
l'occasion des déplacements et nous
l'acceptons d'autant plus que le texte a
évolué là-dessus puisque ceci est soumis
à l'idée du consentement individuel donc
si l'un de nous fait l'objet d'une
vaccination supplémentaire ou d'un test
négatif il appr ou nappera pas le fait
que ces éléments figurent dans le
fichier nous sommes également
favorables à l'idée d'avoir des mesures
comment dire des mesures de sécurité ou
des mesures exceptionnelles en cas de
crise soit de nouveau variant ou
d'autres éléments correspondants soit
sur les déplacements internationaux soit
dans la relation avec l'outre-mer non
pas à l'égard de l'outre-mer du même
mais à l'égard des hypothèses
d'évolution des variants depuis les
territoires voisins pas de commentaires
particuliers pour notre groupe sur
l'article de BIS concernant les
personnels soignants non vaccinés nous
sommes là devant une disposition non
normative qui ne changent pas grand
chose c'est une reformulation de
disposition qui figurait déjà dans le
texte initial deux ou trois observations
rapides pour en terminer notre première
observation
qui a fait qui a été largement développé
en débat concerne la notion de santé
publique et concernant particulier de la
logique de vaccination au-delà des
mesures de type hors de masque au-delà
de l'importance de l'aération et
d'autres éléments la vaccination et très
clairement ce qui a permis à l'ensemble
de notre société de passer cette
situation difficile même si la pandémie
va à l'évidence subsister le rappel
vaccinal contribue donc à l'immunité
dite collective ou populationnelle comme
chacun d'entre vous j'ai pris
connaissance du dernier avis du conseil
scientifique en date du 19 juillet et
celui-ci insiste sur la nécessité de
garder les câbles sur les vaccinations
en particulier de la garder sur les
personnes à risque qui sont donc les
plus de 60 ans comme votre serviteur ou
les personnes ayant les difficultés
respiratoires ce qui nous a un peu gêné
puisque nous sommes autorisés à tout
nous dire avec la liberté qui a pu avoir
chacun dans nos débats c'est cette
espèce de petite musique qui a plané sur
nos débats dans lequel la vaccination
n'apparaît plus nécessaire parce que
elle n'a plus la même efficacité et
malgré le rappel tel un mantrac la
vaccination était nécessaire en réalité
dans le texte chers collègues vous
n'avez plus aucune référence à la
vaccination ce qui est une manière
d'adresser une forme je dirais quasiment
de contre message à nos concitoyens qui
se posent toujours la question est-ce
que je dois vacciner ou est-ce que je ne
dois pas me vacciner nous regrettons un
petit peu cet élément et pour terminer
Monsieur le Ministre a apporté une
touche d'humour supplémentaire à nos
débats en nous indiquant que il se
réjouissait d'avoir pu mettre en place
une nouvelle méthode basée sur le
dialogue nous entendons monsieur le
ministre cette promesse nous considérons
simplement que le dialogue et bilatéral
et vous voudrez bien prier Monsieur le
Ministre chargé des relations avec le
Parlement de considérer que le dialogue
peut concerner plusieurs plusieurs
groupes et à l'intérieur de celui-ci
également le groupe centriste même si
nous nous vexons de rien nous sommes les
canons quand même attentif à la mémoire
des choses merci de votre attention
merci beaucoup la parole est à Madame
Véronique Guillotin pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen pour 5 minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur cher
collègue nous examinons aujourd'hui le
premier texte de la législature issue
d'un accord rapide entre députés et
sénateurs et saute dès la première
lecture le texte a été adopté hier par
l'Assemblée nationale le compromis nous
le connaissons bien ici au Sénat et le
résultat du travail du rapporteur et de
notre assemblée tout entière sur ce
texte en témoigne après le revers imposé
à l'article 2 lors de son examen à
l'Assemblée notre rapporteur Philippe
Bas réintroduit impossible contrôle aux
frontières c'était je dirais essentiel
de se laisser cette possibilité
l'épidémie n'étant pas encore éteinte et
sa résurgence du domaine du possible
toutefois je tiens ici à nouveau à
exprimer mes regrets quant à la voix qui
a été choisie si un contrôle aux
frontières pourra être à nouveau
instaurer
si un contrôle sanitaire pourrait être à
nouveau instauré aux frontières de
l'Hexagone en cas de résurgence
d'avariants au covid ou en cas de
saturation des hôpitaux en outre-mer
seul le test fera foi nous sommes
nombreux à regretter la suppression de
la preuve vaccinale et du certificat de
rétablissement le débat a laissé le
champ libre aux antivax alors que
l'effet sont clairs en plus de protéger
la personne vaccinée le vaccin je le
répète limite la circulation virale et
en réduit la contige la contagiosité
certes les vaccins n'assurent pas une
épine efficacité individuelle et
collective à 100% tout comme d'ailleurs
la fiabilité des tests pour autant
devront new devrions nous ne rien faire
mais le problème est aussi le message
adressé alors que les vaccins anticovid
ont sauvé des millions de vies il serait
aujourd'hui devenu
inutile pour lutter contre la diffusion
d'invariants dangereux avant même que
les autorités médicales ne s'expriment
de la même façon le maintien de
l'article de BIS jugé par le président
de la commission des lois comme
inutiles inefficace et dangereux mais
apparu pour moi effectivement à la fois
inutile mais surtout source de confusion
sur le fond cet article ne change rien
au droit actuel hormis l'auticité de la
réintroduction des soignants non
vaccinés dès que la Haute Autorité de
Santé aura jugé l'épidémie éteinte après
deux avis similaires rendus par le
Conseil Scientifique et l'Académie de
médecine la HAS a tranché la semaine
dernière elle s'est dit à nouveau
favorable au maintien de l'obligation
vaccinale contre le covid 19 pour les
personnels des établissements de santé
et médico-sociaux contenus je cite des
incertitudes sur l'évolution de
l'épidémie et de l'efficacité d'un
schéma vaccinal complet à réduire le
risque d'être infecté et de transmettre
la maladie toutes les autorités
scientifiques s'accordent sur ce sujet
il est donc regrettable de voir nos
assembler parlementaire jouer une forme
d'ambiguïté qui aurait pu mener je
l'écrin à l'adoption d'amendement
autorisant sans délai la réintroduction
trop précoce de soignants suspendus
alors que la période n'y était pas
propice néanmoins cette loi elle mérite
de préserver l'essentiel avec certains
outils de lutte contre l'épidémie d'une
part les systèmes d'information
indispensables au suivi de l'épidémie
contact covid dont la fin est fixée au
31 janvier 2023 et sidait prolongé
jusqu'au 30 juin 2023 pour prendre en
compte les exigences du droit européen
et permettent de suivre le suivi
statistique ou encore le lien avec les
cas contacts d'autre part comme je le
disais la possibilité de contrôler aux
frontières en cas de résurgence nous
nous réjouissons que notre amendement
rejeté en séance mais adopter en
commission mixte paritaire le Parlement
devra ainsi autoriser ce contrôle aux
frontières si les prolongé au-delà de 2
mois le changement de titre souhaité par
notre rapporteur offre d'ailleurs une
clarification bienvenue les réseaux
anti-vacs et antipasses se sont
réactivés à l'approche de l'examen de ce
projet de loi diffusant des messages
mensongers sur une possibilité
prolongation de l'état d'urgence la
nouvelle dénomination permet ainsi
d'établir clairement la fin des régimes
d'exception le plus dur semble être
derrière nous il apparaît donc logique
de revenir à des mesures plus classiques
pour invariant peut-être lui également
plus classique nous devons continuer
collectivement à lutter contre la
désinformation prenant les décisions
fondées sur les données scientifiques le
gouvernement a également un rôle majeur
à jouer dans la communication des
mesures efficaces de la lutte contre le
covid gestes barrière aération des
espaces clos politique vaccinal car à ce
jour il faut le rappeler moins de 30%
des plus de 60 ans ont reçu leur
deuxième dose de rappel mais une
meilleure communication est aussi
attendue envers le corps médical sur les
nouveaux traitements aujourd'hui
disponibles et efficaces dans certaines
indications il en va également de la
responsabilité de chacun avec ces points
de vigilance notre groupe votre a en
faveur de ce texte
merci beaucoup la parole est un homme
estherbenda pour 3 minutes chers
collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur l'accord obtenu lors de la
commission mixte paritaire actes enfants
la sortie des régimes d'exception que
nous subissons depuis le début de
l'épidémie de la covid 19 nous savons en
même temps que l'épidémie n'est pas
encore derrière nous 1300 personnes sont
aujourd'hui hospitalisées en soins
critiques nous nous sommes en plus de
cela pas à l'abri de l'apparition d'un
nouveau variant plus dangereux qui
viendrait accroître l'attention sur
notre système hospitalier à bout de
souffle la lutte contre l'épidémie doit
continuer mais doit aussi en même temps
s'adapter c'est ce que propose ce texte
qui allie à la fois proportionnalité
nécessité de le dispositif la
prorogation du système side pilier de la
lutte contre l'épidémie est
indispensable la date finalement retenue
du 30 juin 2023 me semble toutefois bien
lointaine il aurait été judicieux
d'introduire une clause de revoyure
permettant de réduire l'effectivité du
dispositif si la situation sanitaire le
permet la mise en place d'un certificat
sanitaire de voyage en cas d'apparition
de variant ne pouvant être constitué que
d'un test semble logique à l'heure où
les vaccins perdent leur efficacité sur
l'éradication de la contagiosité des
sous variants je tiens à émettre une
réserve sur le sujet en cas de mise en
place du dispositif seuls les personnes
disposant d'un chemin vaccinal complet
ou d'un certificat de rétablissement
pourrait prétendre à la gratuité des
tests
or ce certificat dispose d'une durée de
validité de six mois de ce fait le test
sera payant passé ce délai je vois dans
cette situation une réelle inégalité en
octobre 2021 la Défenseur des droits
alerté déjà sur le caractère
discriminatoire du Nord remboursement
des tests pour une partie de la
population la solution est pourtant
simple la gratuité des tests pour toutes
et tous vacciner non vacciné et rétabli
de la covid si ce texte incarne notre
relative adaptation à lapidémie il ne
permet pas à l'ensemble de la population
de vivre de façon égale avec ce virus
c'est pour cette raison que je
m'abstiendrai je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame Marie-Pierre de la Gonterie pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain pour 5 minutes chers
collègues
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois monsieur le rapporteur en
montant ces marches
je m'interrogeais sur le fait de savoir
si c'était la dernière fois que nous
examinerions un projet de loi
pour lutter contre le covid et un projet
de loi sur l'urgence sanitaire
vraisemblablement non
parce que c'est bien l'unique mérite de
la version définitive du projet de loi a
été abrogé dans notre législation la
législation d'exception qui a permis de
mettre en place depuis la loi du 23 mars
2020 ces régimes successifs qui nous ont
amenés ici à délibérer et les Français
assis soumettre avec beaucoup de
détermination et de courage
au-delà de cela j'ai entendu vos propos
monsieur le ministre votre gouvernement
s'est présenté avec un texte qu'on
pourrait qualifier de minimales sans
doute parce que c'était la fin d'une
séquence sans doute aussi parce que le
contexte politique désormais à
l'Assemblée nationale ne permettait pas
d'avoir d'ambition des mesures quant à
son adoption définitive mais ce texte
néanmoins a connu des soubresauts
puisque sur deux articles l'un n'a pas
été adopté et que donc au Sénat il a
fallu reprendre le travail ce qui a
comblé de bonheur notre rapporteur qui
s'y met toujours avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasme et de talent
c'est ainsi que le régime d'exception a
été abrogé mais de manière plus grave le
rôle du Parlement est singulièrement du
Sénat s'en est trouvé ABC
parce que finalement
vous l'en fait œuvre de protection de
son groupe politique leur apporteur a
souhaité discuter et élaborer un texte
voté par le Sénat qui serait
intégralement adopté en commission mixte
paritaire puis intégralement adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale et donc j'imagine
aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs en commission mixparitaire
commission que j'ai qualifiée de manière
ironique de potenkins pas un seul mot de
l'Assemblée nationale n'a été retenu et
donc monsieur le ministre si je me
permets de souligner ce point c'est
parce qu'en fait il n'y a pas eu de
compromis il n'a pas eu de dialogue ou
en tout cas avec certains groupes
seulement de cette assemblée vous-même
avez me semble-t-il souhaité que soit
maintenu le vaccin la situation
vaccinale dans le nouveau pass sanitaire
passe voyage qui a été instauré pour
finalement vous résoudre à accepter que
ce ne soit que les tests PCR qui soient
acceptés
et donc finalement en s'alignant d'ores
et déjà sur la position de ce dont nous
avons vu désormais la parole fleurie ici
celle de quelques collègues antivax et
je garderai de cette soirée de projet de
loi un sentiment un peu triste de retour
en arrière nous avons effectivement vu 7
collègues du groupe LR s'abstenir sur la
motion d'y recevabilité de Monsieur
ravier nous avons vu effectivement
retirer du Pass sanitaire le vaccin
alors que depuis deux ans nous plaidons
sans relâche auprès de nos compatriotes
pour qu'il soit vaccinés
revacinés revaxiner et qu'il y a encore
des campagnes de publicité à la
télévision nous avons vu surgir à
l'initiative du rapporteur un article
sur la réintégration des soignants
article dont le rapporteur Philippe Bas
indiquait que il était au fond
simplement pour tracer une route alors
même qu'il a été parfaitement compris
par ceux qui sont concernés et par les
antivax comme étant la porte ouverte à
cette réintégration qui nous le savons
serait totalement
choquante le président de la commission
des lois ça a été rappelé tout à l'heure
l'a dit en commission mixparitaire puis
publiquement cet article est à la fois
inutile et dangereux voire
inconstitutionnel mais malgré cela notre
rapporteur est l'ensemble de la majorité
du Sénat qu'on a connu très exigeant sur
ces sujets néanmoins accepter de passer
par dessus cette difficulté
importante et voter ce texte pour
privilégier le poids supposé que le
groupe LR s'apprête à remplir auprès de
la majorité présidentielle
bon courage
et je ne sais comment demain le groupe
LR pourra s'adapter aux différentes
exigences de la majorité présidentielle
je pense qu'ici nous aurons et vous
aurez à revenir en arrière sur un
certain nombre de sujets qui vous
divisent car vous n'êtes pas unis sur
ces sujets j'espère que le président bar
retrouvera la grande rigueur à laquelle
il nous a habitués pour notre part vous
l'avez compris en raison de la question
du vaccin en raison de la réintégration
des soignants mais aussi de la
prolongation du système sidepse comme en
commission mixparitaire et commencer
ensemble première lecture nous nous
obtiendrons merci
la parole est à monsieur le Président
Alain Richard pour le groupe de
rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendants
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
nous avons donc à passer à nos adapter à
un changement de situation sanitaire en
dans l'ensemble favorable sur lequel
vous avez fait les réserves légitimes
monsieur le ministre
ceci se fait à travers un projet de loi
qui avait deux objets concrets le
maintien des systèmes d'information
permettant de contrôler la poursuite des
de diffusion des virus et d'autres parts
un moyen de contrôle potentiel des
mouvements transfrontaliers en cas de
remontée d'une circulation de virus aux
effets menaçants
c'était ça l'objet de la proposition du
gouvernement qui a été peu contestée sur
le principe
l'accord conclut en commission
mixparitaire permet l'entrée en
application de ces deux mesures et c'est
là principalement ou sinon uniquement
alors qu'elles avaient été frappés d'une
certaine incertitude après le débat de
première lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
nous sommes pour notre groupe satisfait
de cette aboutissement et nous avons
essayé de contribuer
à ce résultat dans la séance plénière
ici et à la Commission et à la
commission mixte paritaire ça nous
paraissait de bon sens
simplement le texte de lieu aussi à une
série de débats complémentaires pour
l'ensemble honorable mais dans certains
sont purement budgétaires voire
administratifs en ce qui concerne les
conditions par exemple de remboursement
ou plus fondamentaux mais d'un tout
autre ordre lorsqu'il s'agit de
l'évolution de nos capacités
hospitalières
et donc il était quelque part un peu une
facilité de se servir de ces arguments
là qui étaient extérieurs à l'objet du
texte qui lui répond à une nécessité
immédiate
pour ce comment dire se distraire de
l'objet du texte éventuellement se
proposer des votes qu'il y avait un
caractère d'alibi
il ne semble que il reste un point
important qui résulte de notre accord
qui est le rapport à venir
parce que
les missions sont publiques les
obligations de l'État pour faire face
aux crises sanitaires
déjà connu ou prétentiel sont une
responsabilité première de l'État à
laquelle le Parlement doit apporter
toute son attention et donc nous pensons
que le ministre d'ailleurs en a fait
bien l'état tout à l'heure dans son
intervention il est important que les
uns et les autres nous nous mobilisions
pour participer à cette évaluation de ce
qui a fonctionné et de ce qui est
reproductible dans les mesures de
précaution de prévention qui sont de la
nature même du Code de Santé publique
de manière que nous soyons mieux
préparés que nous tirions les
conséquences partagées des du
déroulement de cette crise avec ces
différentes phases
mais en tout cas nous considérons que la
manière dont le compromis a été atteint
est honorable pour tous les participants
et que en tout cas nous constatons que
les votes ont évolué positivement à
l'Assemblée nationale
et c'est vrai en particulier de nos
partenaires du groupe socialiste qui ont
voté pour l'Assemblée nationale ce qui
prouve que il n'est pas totalement
dépourvu de mérite que le texte n'a pas
d'effet sur l'obligation vaccinale sinon
un point que le rapporteur Philippe Bas
a bien fait de faire apparaître dans les
débats qui que lorsque le gouvernement
réfléchira à une évolution et
éventuellement une levée de l'obligation
vaccinale il le fasse de façon
différencier car la situation des
soignants directs c'est j'ose dire des
agents en contact direct avec les
malades et j'y ajouterai en contact
direct avec les personnes hébergées en
établissement spécialisé je pense en
particulier aux EHPAD que
la nécessité de leur obligation
vaccinale n'est pas forcément la même
que c'est l'applicable notamment aux
pompiers ou celle applicable au
personnel administratif du système
hospitalier donc cet outil là a été créé
il permet donc d'ouvrir une perspective
tout en maintenant évidemment
l'importance de la vaccination et nous
serons parmi ceux qui soutiendront le
gouvernement lorsqu'ils poursuivra
l'effort pour vacciner l'ensemble des
Français et en particulier les plus
vulnérables nous avons donc toutes les
raisons de nous satisfaire de cet accord
de CMP que nous allons voter très
favorablement
merci beaucoup
à Monsieur Alain Marc pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoires
pour 5 minutes chers collègues
merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues bien que la
pandémie de covid 19 ne soit pas
terminée nous nous a prêtons à tourner
la page de l'état d'urgence sanitaire il
y a quelques jours seulement notre pays
connaissait près de 200 000
contaminations par jour des variantes
continuent d'apparaître ça et là comme
le variant Centaure fort heureusement
ces contaminations n'ont plus les
conséquences dramatiques massives d'il y
a deux ans les hospitalisations ne
submergent plus notre système de santé
bien que le virus continue cependant de
tuer
la couverture vaccinale de notre pays
permet néanmoins de pouvoir faire face à
l'affût de patients ayant besoin de
soins dans ces conditions le
gouvernement n'a pas souhaité progroger
l'état d'urgence sanitaire après le 31
juillet il a proposé au Parlement de
prolonger certaines mesures de veille de
surveillance de l'épidémie
après un examen rapide par les deux
Chambres du Parlement la commission
mixte paritaire et parvenu à un accord
sur ce texte reprenant bon nombre des
ajouts et modifications adoptées par le
Sénat afin d'envoyer un message clair à
nos concitoyens notre commission a fait
le choix d'abroger les dispositions de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire qui était
voué à devenir caduque le 31 juillet
les traitements des données nécessaires
à la surveillance de l'épidémie sont
prorogées de quelques mois bon nombre de
situations exigent cependant le recueil
du consentement des personnes concernées
le Sénat a par ailleurs rétabli
l'article 2 du projet de loi qui prévoit
le contrôle des déplacements entre les
outre-mer et la métropole ainsi que ceux
entre l'étranger et le territoire
national cet article avait été rejeté à
l'Assemblée nationale bien que les
amendements de suppression ne se pas été
adoptés il était important de rétablir
la possibilité pour le gouvernement en
cas de menace sanitaire grave de réguler
ses déplacements pour limiter une
propagation de variants le cas échéon
nous regrettons cependant que seul un
test négatif serait alors exigé des
voyageurs à l'heure où la quatrième dose
est ouverte aux personnes vulnérables il
nous paraît nécessaire de rappeler à nos
concitoyens à quel point la vaccination
est utile et importante nous aurions
souhaité qu'un justificatif de
vaccination ou qu'un certificat de
rétablissement puisse suffire le cas
échéant
[Musique]
si aujourd'hui le virus n'est plus aussi
dangereux si les contraintes s'allège si
la vie des Français se dirige de plus en
plus vers un retour à la normale c'est
bien grâce à ceux qui ont fait le choix
de ce vacciner et non pas à ceux qui
l'ont refusé cependant certains parmi
nous continuent de penser le contraire
malgré la réalité qui se présente à
leurs yeux regardez donc du côté de la
Chine sans couverture vaccinale dans son
réduit à confiner largement leur
population
même si ce projet de loi contient des
mesures nécessaires certaines d'entre
elles ne satisfont pas pleinement
l'ensemble de notre groupe aussi chacun
d'entre nous votera-t-il en fonction de
ses convictions
merci chers collègues
explication de votre sont terminées donc
conformément l'article 42 alinéa 12 du
règlement je vais mettre au voile
ensemble du projet de loi dans la
rédaction résultant du texte élaboré par
la commission mixte de paritaire j'ai
été saisie d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe les républicains
sur les conclusions de la CMP il va être
procédé pardon ce que tu as un public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
alors voici le résultat du scrutin
numéro 125 sur l'ensemble du texte
contenu de l'ensemble des délégations de
vote accordée par les sénateurs au
groupe politique et notifié à la
présidence nombre de votants 343 nombre
de suffrages exprimés 239 pour
l'adoption 209 contre 30 le Sénat a
adopté
mes chers collègues je vais lever la
séance prochaine séance Mercredi 27
juillet à 15h pour les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement la séance
est levée
[Musique]